Also wenn ich jetzt 16 wäre, würde
zugucken, da würde ich sagen "Leckt mich
doch am Arsch! Macht eure Scheiße
allein!" Ich meine Menschen mit scharfen Verstand
und die Lebensfreude haben und an eine Zukunft
denken, wenn man die nicht wählen
lassen will, dann
ist man wirklich bekloppt.
13 Fragen. Hier kommt die erste
Frage: Brauchen wir ein Wahlrecht ab 16?
Wenn ihr sagt "Ja, finde ich eine gute
Idee" dann positioniert euch bitte
auf dem grünen Feld und wenn ihr gesagt
"Nee, keine so gute Idee" dann bitte
auf gelb. Wo ihr steht, das wissen
wir jetzt. Aber was meint ihr? Ist Wählen ab
18, so wie es jetzt ist, genau die richtige
Idee? Oder ist es ein bisschen
unfair vielleicht? Gerade jetzt, wo so
viele junge Menschen sich politisch
engagieren in Sachen Klimaschutz,
in Gerechtigkeitsfragen, Leute, die sagen
"Hey, wir wollen nicht nur mitreden,
wir wollen auch mitentscheiden." Und zwar
nicht erst ab 18, sondern vielleicht
sogar schon ab 16 oder noch früher. Oder sagt
ihr "Naja, viele 16-jährige, die haben
ja vielleicht auch noch nicht so
den Überblick. Manche schon, aber
eben nicht alle und wenn die dann aber alle
wählen dürfen, vielleicht keine
so gute Idee. Also wo würdet ihr euch
positionieren? Auf dem grünen Feld, Ja,
mit 16? Oder auf dem gelben Nee, lieber so
bleiben wie es ist? So, 13 Fragen, die Regeln
sind klar: Wenn ihr in einem Punkt
der Gegenseite zustimmt,
dann geht gerne einen Schritt
auf sie zu und wenn ihr sagt, das,
was du gerade sagst, ist totaler Bullshit,
dann geht gerne auch einen Schritt
zurück. Also mein Ziel ist es ja, dass ihr am Ende
alle hier im Kompromissfeld landet,
das wäre natürlich toll, wenn das klappt.
Hier kommt Frage Nr. 2 und die geht
an Friedrich: Du bist ja auf deiner Seite
derjenige, der vielleicht am weitesten
von den 16 Jahren entfernt ist. Warum glaubst
du trotzdem ist das eine gute
Idee, Wahlrecht ab 16 einzuführen?
Die 16-Jährigen sind sehr gut
drauf. Die sind sehr stark und sehr schlau
und die kümmern sich einmal mehr um Nachhaltigkeit
als die Leute in meinem
Alter und die kümmern sich auch mehr
um die Zukunft, weil die haben ja noch
eine und deshalb ist 16 sehr gut.
Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, es gibt
Entwicklung. Erst durften die Frauen
nicht wählen, dann war 21 erwachsen, dann war 18
erwachsen und jetzt könnte 16
erwachsen sein. Und das wird definitiv eine bessere
Welt, wenn ich sehe, was die so
umtreibt, die Kids, das ist auf jeden Fall besser
-als die Alten.
-Jetzt sagt Friedrich, die 16-Jährigen sind
gut drauf, die engagieren sich, die machen
viel, auch z.B. in Sachen Klimafragen.
-Überzeugt euch das?
-Die Frage, ob jemand gut drauf ist oder
sich für Politik interessiert oder zur Wahl
geht, spielt bei der Frage des
Wahlalters keine Rolle. Sonst müssten
wir ja eine Behörde einführen, die testet,
ob jemand gut drauf ist und sich
für Politik interessiert.
Einen Wahl-Führerschein
einzuführen bin ich strikt dagegen.
-Gegenmeinung?
-Da geht es ja um mehr als nur Reife,
sondern auch wirklich ja den politischen
Willen, den unsere Generation seit
den letzten Jahren immer wieder auf die Straße
gebracht hat. Ich bin mit Herzblut
für das Wahlalter ab 16, weil es endlich
Zeit ist, den 1,5 Millionen jungen
Menschen, die gerade 16 und 17
Jahre alt sind, ihre politischen Grundrechte
zu geben. Und natürlich wollen wir auch nicht,
dass alle Menschen über 18 dann
überprüft werden. Aber eigentlich
stände es doch so vielen Menschen zu, weil eben
das Wahlalter nicht an die Volljährigkeit
geknüpft ist.
Also Vielen Dank, dass du
meiner Argumentation zustimmst. Die Frage
der politischen Reife und des
politischen Interesses ist kein Kriterium.
Leo, du bist 16 Jahre alt. Du bist
trotzdem nicht für ein Wahlrecht für Leute
ab 16, das heißt, du selbst
willst kein Wahlrecht haben? Warum nicht?
Ich würde schon gerne wählen gehen bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl. Aber es geht ja
nicht nur um mich. Wenn man aber von einer Generation
spricht, muss man immer
die ganze Generation betrachten. Und klar,
Fridays for future hat gezeigt: Es gibt
viele Jugendliche, die sich
engagieren. Das ist aber nur ein Teil der Generation.
Ich glaube, dass ein Wahlrecht ab
16 dazu führt, dass die Generation Z,
besonders die 16 bis 18-Jährigen
falsch repräsentiert und dargestellt werden,
weil nur ein bestimmtes Klientel wählen
gehen würde. Das sind die jungen Menschen,
deren Eltern ein hohes Einkommen
haben, einen überdurchschnittlich hohen
Bildungsgrad und meist
aus Deutschland kommen.
Warum ist das bei 16-Jährigen ein Argument,
aber nicht bei 30-Jährigen?
Weil ich glaube, dass die Politisierung
auch später stattfinden kann. Dass viele
vielleicht mit dem ersten Job, mit dem ersten
Gehalt, vielleicht irgendwann
mit Kindern ganz anders auf die Themen
schauen, die politisch diskutiert werden
und das eben im Alter von 16 leider
noch nicht so oft der Fall ist. Ich sehe ja
Politikunterricht selbst jede Woche und merke
da einfach auch dass das viele nicht
-dazu bringen würde, wählen zu gehen.
-Tracy, warum gehst du nicht nach vorne?
Ich bin zurückgegangen. Also ich müsste
eigentlich einen Schritt vor,
einen Schritt zurück. Ich glaube,
Wahlen und sozioökonomische Gründe hängen
zusammen. Und trotzdem finde ich es nicht
richtig zu sagen, dass z.B. Menschen,
die aus klassistisch
benachteiligten Haushalten kommen, migrantisch sind,
automatisch nicht wählen gehen würden.
Ich sehe überhaupt keinen Grund, jetzt nicht
dieses Update für die Demokratie
einzuführen, weil junge Menschen einfach
schon in informellen Wegen so oft
gezeigt haben, dass sie politisch aktiv sind
und für mich ist das Wahlrecht ab
16 ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung
für eine zukunftsfähige Demokratie.
Zum Beispiel bei mir ist das der Fall:
Meine Mutter hat noch keinen
deutschen Pass, ich habe einen deutschen Pass.
Ich könnte jetzt wählen gehen. Und Menschen
aus migrantischen Communities
zu sagen, Ihr seid per se nicht
politisch, weil ihr aus diesen Haushalten kommt
und ihnen auch nicht die Chance zu geben,
Parteien zu kreieren z.B. die sich genau
um diese Fragen kümmern,
finde ich mega problematisch.
Es geht mir nicht darum, irgendjemanden
zu diskriminieren und auszuschließen. Es geht
mir darum, dass alle teilhaben können.
Und wenn wir uns die Landtagswahlen angucken
ist es so, dass die Studien ergeben
haben, dass eben privilegierte, jüngere Menschen
-eher wählen gehen.
-Aber da kann man ja etwas aktiv gegen tun.
Mit dem Wahlrecht könnten
ja Bildungskampagnen entstehen.
Beratungsbüros entstehen, die sich genau
um diese Zielgruppen kümmern.
Also wenn wir ein Land haben wollen,
in dem Demokratie aktiv gelebt
wird und nicht nur von eben weiß,
männlich sozialisiert usw.. Dann
sollten wir uns genau diese Themen anschauen
und nicht sagen, das war schon immer
ein Argument, also diese Menschen sind einfach
nicht politisch oder aufgrund ihrer
Herkunft, aufgrund ihres Einkommens werden
sie dieses Wahlrecht nicht
wahrnehmen, sondern gerade da ansetzen.
Das ist auch kein Argument. Die zentrale
Frage ist doch: Warum soll jemand,
der nicht die Verantwortung für die Folgen
seines eigenen Handelns trägt,
die Verantwortung für die Gesellschaft
insgesamt mit übernehmen? Ich bin
gegen ein Wahlrecht ab 16, weil ich finde,
Volljährigkeit und Wahlrecht gehören
zusammen, kann man nicht
entkoppeln. Jemand, der selber die Verantwortung
für die Folgen seines eigenen
Handelns nicht tragen soll nach Auffassung
der Gesellschaft, kann auch nicht
für die Gesellschaft insgesamt entscheiden.
-Genau.
-Warum?
Weil wir für das Wahlrecht ein objektives
Kriterium brauchen. Ursprünglich war ja
Wahlrecht mal, ähnlich wie Volljährigkeit,
21 Jahre mit der Gründung
der Bundesrepublik. Das hat sich Mitte
der 60er Jahre geändert. Und damals wurde
die Wehrpflicht eingerichtet ins Grundgesetz
und dann war das Argument
Wehrpflicht ab 18, dann muss man auch die Volljährigkeit
auf 18 absenken und damit
das Wahlrecht auch entsprechend
absenken. Diese Argumentation leuchtet mir ein.
Interessanterweise wird aber die Absenkung
der Volljährigkeit nicht gefordert.
-Deine Antwort?
-Also ich finde es ein bisschen perfide,
jetzt hier das zu vermischen, weil das eine mit dem anderen
nichts zu tun hat.
Vor den Demonstrationen, vor Fridays
for future hätte niemand über Klimapolitik
geredet. Es gibt verschiedene Grenzen
von Altern, weswegen man mit 16 schon z.B.
Ausbildungen anfangen kann, weswegen
man sich mit 14 für einen Gott entscheiden
kann, aber nicht für die nächsten
vier Jahre Bundesregierung. Mit 14 ist man
-auch teilweise strafmündig.
-Nein das ist nicht richtig.
-Teilweise strafmündig.
-Warum dann 16? Also nach unserem
-Rechtssystem ist es so...
-Ich bin noch nicht fertig.
...bis 14 ist man Kind und ab 14
Jugendlicher. Warum forderst du dann 16
-und nicht 15 oder 13 oder 12?
-Bei mir war es sogar mit 13, dass ich
gegen AKWs demonstriert habe in Freiburg
und ich hätte mich mit 13 vielleicht schon
für ein Wahlalter entschieden. Jetzt
ist es aber so, dass es schon Kommunalwahlen
gibt und teilweise auch Landtagswahlen,
wo man ab 16 wählen darf. Das heißt,
Landesregierungen haben schon aktiv
gesagt 16, das ist eine politische Reife,
jetzt kannst du auch wählen. Warum darf
man denn dann in der Kommune entscheiden,
dass Geld in X oder Y gesteckt
wird? Aber man darf nicht entscheiden, wer
im nächsten Ministerium für Wirtschaft
sitzt und die Klimapolitik an die Wand
-fährt.
-Ich darf ganz kurz was sagen. Leo ist
gerade auf dich zugegangen und das ist
eigentlich das Spannende an dieser Sache.
-Warum bist du auf sie zugegangen?
-Weil man gesehen hat, junge Menschen
können viel bewegen. Bei Fridays
for future ist immer die Frage: Wie viele
waren wirklich unter 18? Also wenn ich in meiner
Schulklasse gucke, war es nicht so,
dass die halbe Klasse jeden Freitag
auf der Straße war. Und zu den Landtagswahlen
möchte ich sagen, dass da nochmal
ein Unterschied finde ich besteht. Gerade
ich komme aus Bremen, das ist
nochmal ein Stück regionaler. Ob vielleicht
der eine Spielplatz gebaut wird,
was mit der Galopprennbahn passiert, kommt
da eine Konzerthalle hin oder ähnliches?
Da ist die bundesweite Politik nochmal
ein Stück weiter entfernt, glaube
ich und auch weniger interessant für Leute,
-die sich überhaupt nicht interessieren.
-Wir reden ja noch ein bisschen über die
Festsetzung eines Alters. Du sagst dir
ist das zu willkürlich, du willst das koppeln
an eine Volljährigkeit. Jetzt hat
sie gesagt: Na ja, wir haben ja mehr
oder weniger willkürliche
Entscheidungen auch in anderen Fällen. 14 hast du gesagt
Religionsmündigkeit, teilweise
Strafmündigkeit. Das sind ja durchaus
-Argumente, oder?
-Aber wenn wir uns die Realitäten
anschauen, dann sehen wir doch ganz
klar, dass es immer mehr davon weg kommt,
dass Leute mit 16 anfangen,
Ausbildungen zu machen, sondern wir haben
eine regelrechte Überakademisierung.
Ich finde, dass wir in Deutschland einen ganz
sinnvollen Zusammenhang aus staatsbürgerlichen
Rechten und Pflichten
haben und dass jede Abweichung von der Volljährigkeit
rein willkürlich wäre.
Gerade bei Fridays for future sagen
90% "Ich habe ein Abi" oder "Ich strebe
ein Diplom, Doktor oder Masterabschluss
an" Und das zeigt doch, dass sich
die Ausbildungen immer
länger nach hinten verschieben aber
auch die Familiengründungen. Das heißt,
der Zeitpunkt, wo ich aktiv Verantwortung
für mich, aber auch für andere
übernehme, verlagert sich nach hinten im Vergleich
zu früher. Und deshalb verstehe ich es nicht,
wie man dann argumentiert und sagt,
-wir müssen das Wahlalter jetzt vorsetzen.
-Friedrich?
Also wenn ich jetzt 16 wäre, würde
zugucken, da würde ich sagen leckt mich
doch am Arsch. Macht eure Scheiße
allein. Ich meine, das Politischste,
was die jungen Leute ja auch machen,
ist kaufen. Die kaufen schon besser
ein als die Alten. Die essen
weniger Fleisch. Ich kenne niemanden
von den jungen Leuten, die sich ein Auto
besorgen wollen hier in Berlin. Die leben
ganz anders. Und wenn man die jetzt
nicht in das politische System reinholt,
dann lebt das politische System ganz
schön wackelig, weil über kurz oder lang sind
die halt nicht mehr dabei. Und dann
heißt es das System hat keine Wähler mehr,
sondern nur irgendwelche Idioten, sag
ich mal, die nicht richtig gut drauf sind,
weil Menschen mit scharfen Verstand und die Lebensfreude
haben und an eine Zukunft
denken, wenn man die nicht wählen
lassen will, dann ist man wirklich bekloppt.
-Dann ist man richtig bekloppt.
-Ich glaube wir müssen mal ein bisschen
davon wegkommen, dass alle
Jugendlichen sich vegan ernähren, nicht mehr Auto
fahren wollen mehr und sowas. Also es gibt
da eine ganze Breite an Jugendlichen.
Klar sind viele da bewusster.
Aber viele eben auch nicht.
Ich bin immer noch darauf gespannt:
Wollt ihr die Volljährigkeit auf 16 Jahre
oder 14 oder 7 absenken? Das heißt
die volle Verantwortung für die Folgen des
-eigenen Verhaltens.
-Deine Antwort?
Nein, natürlich nicht, weil wir auch nicht
sagen, dass Volljährigkeit
-an ein Wahlrecht geknüpft werden soll.
-Ich wollte gerade sagen: Du siehst da
einen Widerspruch, sie nicht.
Warum? Warum wollt ihr das nicht absetzen
-wenn 16-Jährige so mündig sind?
-Ich verstehe das Argument auch nicht. Also
ich hätte jetzt nicht so wirklich
etwas dagegen, ehrlich gesagt, das abzusenken.
Vielleicht ist es auch eine Zeitgeist
Frage: Müssen wir uns damit
auseinandersetzen, ob junge Menschen
heute einfach komplett anders aufwachsen
und vielleicht eben schon
viel mündiger sind, als wir denken?
Und wenn es um digitale Medien
geht sehen wir: Die junge Generation hat
den Erwachsenen so viel voraus,
weil sie damit geboren sind, ob sie wollten
oder nicht. Die haben einfach mehr
Plan so. Und das kann eben in anderen Dingen
auch passieren. Wenn jetzt
gerade eine Krisensituation so krass ist,
dass es dein ganzes Aufwachsen
prägt, vielleicht sind das dann die Experten
dieser Zeit. Vielleicht sollten
wir die einfach jetzt mit einbeziehen
und unser ganzes
politisches System reformieren.
Ich halte Volljährigkeit mit 18 für in Ordnung.
Aber wenn du sagst, ich möchte
das Wahlrecht auf 16 absenken und die Volljährigkeit,
dann bist du logisch.
-Aber das wäre ja eine Kompromisslösung.
-Dann musst du mit deinen beiden Nachbarn
reden, warum sie gegen eine Absenkung
der Volljährigkeit sind.
-Ne, mach das nicht.
-Na ja, das können wir dann ja noch weiter
-diskutieren.
-Möglicherweise gibt es ja auch den Punkt,
dass jemand sagt, ich will die beiden
Aspekte gar nicht miteinander kombinieren.
-Ich muss einmal dazu noch kurz was sagen.
-Wo willst du hin? Du willst beim Alter
-bleiben?
-Zur Volljährigkeit. Ich glaube, wenn man
realistisch mal junge Menschen fragt:
Wollt ihr wählen? Die Volljährigkeit wird
mit runter gesetzt oder es bleibt
alles so, würde sich ein Großteil dafür
entscheiden, dass alles so bleibt.
Also ich kenne sehr sehr wenig Jugendliche,
die sagen würden ja, ich will mit 16
volljährig sein, für alles haften,
was ich tue, für alles
verantwortlich sein. Also das ist glaube ich nicht
realistisch, wenn man da die Jugendlichen
selbst fragt.
Ist auch gar nicht das Thema, was debattiert
wird, ob die Volljährigkeit
-herabgesetzt werden sollte.
-Ich finde es auch krass zu sagen, dass in
der Kommune z.B. weniger
wichtige Entscheidungen getroffen werden.
-Realitätsnäher.
-Das Argument ist für mich ein anderes
Argument. Das Argument ist: In der Kommune
wähle ich ja nicht die Legislative.
Ich wähle keine Organe, die gesetzgeberisch
tätig werden. Ich wähle
die Exekutive. Das ist ein massiver
Unterschied, weil die Exekutive ausführt,
die Legislative kann Gesetze verändern.
Ich will nur sagen, es lässt sich durchaus
sehr logisch begründen, warum wir in der Kommune
mit 16 wählen dürfen und eben
-auf Bundes und Landesebene nicht.
-Die Irritation, warum Stephan auf einmal
ganz vorne steht,
müssen wir kurz auflösen.
Ja, ich stimme dir zu, dass es unlogisch
ist, dass man Kommunalwahlrecht in allen
Bundesländern ab 16 hat und dass bei anderen
Wahlen nicht hat. Warum ist
das so? Weil das Kommunalwahlrecht
nicht mit Zweidrittelmehrheit geändert werden
muss, sondern mit einfacher
Mehrheit in allen Bundesländern. Überall dort,
wo das Wahlrecht an Zweidrittelmehrheit
geknüpft ist, im Bund und bei fast allen
Bundesländern, ist das Wahlalter auf 18
geblieben. Das halte ich auch für richtig,
weil Wahlrecht kein Spielball von politischen
Interessen sein darf. Also
und wenn ich das noch sagen darf,
so zu tun, als seien Kommunalwahlen so
ein Spielfeld, so nicht so wichtig.
Und da könnte man ja 16-Jährige... halte
ich für eine Herabsetzung
von Kommunalwahlen.
Stimmt ihr zu? Tracy, was glaubst
du denn, würde sich politisch ändern,
wenn Jugendliche,
16-Jährige wählen dürfen?
Also ich glaube, dass grundsätzlich
ein Umdenken entstehen würde,
weil der Durchschnitt der Bundestagsabgeordneten
ist über 50 Jahre
alt. Also in allen Parteien.
Auch bei den Grünen so 49 oder so...
Entschuldigung, und der würde
sinken, wenn 16-Jährige wählen dürfen?
Nein, aber es könnten mehr
Menschen gewählt werden, die einen Bezug haben
zu diesen jungen Menschen,
also 18-jährige Direktmandate z.B.
Du willst es doch von der politischen
Haltung abhängig machen, also du wirst
auch einen 60-Jährigen wählen, wenn er deine politischen
Ziele unterstützt?
Aber den 20-Jährigen nicht, wenn er nicht
deine Meinung vertritt. Es hat also
-mit dem Alter nichts zu tun.
-Total. Aber ich glaube, dass es schon
wichtig ist zu sehen, was für Lebensrealitäten
spiegelt ein 18-jähriger
Bundestagsabgeordneter wieder, was ein 50-jähriger?
Und zu sehen, es sind so
krass viele alte weiße Männer,
sag ich jetzt einfach mal, im Bundestag.
Und meine These ist: Ich würde eben
Menschen wählen, die mir auch entsprechen,
die mir ein Vorbild sind
wie Aminata Touré zum Beispiel.
Also nichts Alter,
sondern die politische Überzeugung.
Nein, nein, nein. Es geht darum, dass es Menschen
gibt, die die Lebensrealität
der jungen Menschen widerspiegeln und dass auch junge
Kandidaten z.B. die Möglichkeit
bekommen, wirklich eine Zielgruppe
zu haben, die sozusagen auf Augenhöhe ist.
Ich bin in deinen Worten
ein "alter weißer Mann", 65.
Bist du, ja. Und ich bin
eine junge schwarze Frau.
Und ich behaupte, dass meine politische
Überzeugung, für die ich arbeite, mehr
für die junge Generation
tut als Fridays for future.
Mich würde mal eure Meinung
interessieren: Was glaubt ihr, wenn wir das Wahlalter
senken, gibt es dann einen Schub in Richtung
mehr Perspektive für Jugendliche?
Würden die Parteien sich vielleicht
ändern und ihre Wahlprogramme eventuell sogar
ändern? Mehr auf junge Leute
zugehen? Schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare
und dazu natürlich würde ich auch gern
mal wissen von dir, Sarah, du bist ja nun
-politisch aktiv.
-Ja.
Würde sich deine Partei vielleicht für die 1,5
Millionen Wahlberechtigten, die dann
dazu käme, nicht doch ein bisschen
ins Zeug legen und sagen Hey, wir können
die nicht ganz außer Acht lassen, wir müssen
noch weiter an junge Leute denken.
-Klingt doch eigentlich logisch.
-Ich erlebe gerade sehr stark auch wie
viele ältere Abgeordnete sagen Ja,
Fridays for future ist vielleicht nicht gerade
die Bewegung, die aus dem konservativen
Spektrum kommt, aber lasst doch mal
die Ideen aufnehmen. Ich habe Enkel,
ich habe Kinder und das spielt ja auch alles
eine Rolle. Also es ist mit nichten
so, dass sich nur junge Menschen einsetzen
könnten für junge Interessen. Und ich möchte
nochmal den Punkt herausstellen,
dass man sich in Parteien
engagieren sollte, wenn man mitreden möchte,
weil die Parteien sehr viel Macht
haben und gerade da sich für die jungen
Interessen einsetzen. Das tue ich,
seitdem ich 14 bin und habe damit gute
-Erfahrungen.
-Das finde ich auch total überzeugend.
Übrigens du findest es auch überzeugend.
Aber es hat die Frage nicht beantwortet,
denn die Frage war ja: Würde sich
dann nicht z.B. die Union dann noch mehr
für junge Interessen (einsetzen),
weil 1,5 Millionen Wahlberechtigte sind 1,5
-Millionen Stimmen.
-Ich glaube nicht, dass sie aus reinem
Opportunismus sagen würde: Das sind
speziell junge Interessen, für die würden
-wir uns jetzt mehr einsetzen.
-Der gute Punkt ist, du bist nach vorne
-gelaufen. Warum?
-Bei der Position, dass man natürlich auch
in Parteien eintreten kann, um sich
seiner politischen Wut oder auch seinem
Engagement irgendwie Luft zu machen.
Da würde ich dir voll zustimmen.
Aber trotzdem: Ich bin z.B. jetzt mit 16
zur Grünen Jugend gekommen. Wie liebend
gerne hätte ich den nächsten
Bundestag mitbestimmt. Wie liebend gerne hätte
ich nicht nur Wahlkampf Flyer
verteilt, sondern auch wirklich meine Partei dann
wählen können, wir liebend gerne habe
ich zwar an den Kommunalwahlen teilgenommen,
aber für die anderen Wahlen hat es nicht
gereicht. Es sollte doch nicht dabei
reichen, dass ich Aktionen auf der Straße
mache, dass ich wirklich für grüne Inhalte
streite, aber dann unter 18 noch
nicht wählen darf. Das macht für mich keinen
-logischen Schluss.
-So Leo, kannst das nachvollziehen?
Das spricht ja für sich. Also ich kann
das auch nachvollziehen. Ich würde gerne
auch bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl wählen.
Ja also man kann es auch andersherum
sagen: Wer nicht wählen gehen will,
-muss ja nicht mit 16 wählen gehen.
-Nein aber die Voraussetzungen sind ja für
alle Menschen unterschiedlich. Das habe
ich ja versucht, am Anfang schon
klarzumachen. Andersherum: Es wählt
ja nicht mal die Hälfte der Jugendlichen
-bei den Landtagswahlen.
-Immer von diesem Ist-Zustand auszugehen
und zu sagen, aber so viele
Jugendliche wählen ja nicht. Ja, warum tun wir uns
dann nicht den Arsch aufreißen, dass sie es machen?
Weil in der Jugend steckt so
viel politische Kraft und die, die das schon
äußern und sagen "Hey, wir wollen
mitentscheiden", die bremsen wir dann
auch noch, weil wir dann auf den Rest schauen,
vielleicht der auf Instagram
hängt. Anstatt zu sagen: Hey, cool,
dass ihr das schon macht. Ihr könnt
die anderen inspirieren. Weil wir brauchen
eure Kraft und eure Bedürfnisse,
eure Meinungen. Weil wir können gar nicht so
denken. In 20 Jahren sind wir nämlich
tot oder in 20 Jahren ich hab schon Familie.
Ich bin schon im Job, ich habe ganz
andere Denkstrukturen, ganz andere Denkautobahn
mir schon angerichtet. Und da finde
ich wirklich... Also ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr als Junge Union den Schuss
nicht gehört habt. Zu sagen "Ja, die junge
Wählerschaft, das ist
jetzt eine Gruppe wie jede andere."
Das ist deine Meinung, dass du
sagst: Ja, die Älteren setzen sich nicht
für die junge Generation ein,
deshalb müssen die jungen Menschen wählen.
Also ich würde die Gesellschaft gar
nicht so in der Mitte spalten. Ich kann euch ja
mal aus dem Innenleben der Union
erzählen. Da heißt es an vielen Stellen: Was ist
denn unsere Klimapolitik? Wir müssen
uns positionieren. Übernehmen
wir das von den Grünen oder was sagen
Fridays for future? Natürlich gehen
wir darauf ein und natürlich
haben wir viel bewirkt.
Friedrich, wo ordnest du denn das hier
alles ein gerade? Es ist das, was hier
auch parteipolitisch erzählt wird auch in deinem
Sinne? Würdest du eine ganz andere
-Partei gründen? Wo stehen wir denn gerade?
-Also ich bin ganz froh, dass ich hier
stehe. Meine Truppe ist richtig gut
aufgestellt, sehr gute Leute. Ich merke
aber auch, dass ich gar nicht so
schlau bin. Ich bin gar nicht so ausgebildet,
was die Finessen des Politischen
betrifft. Die ganzen Scharmützeln...
Übrigens wie viele von unseren
Zuschauer*innen auch nicht. Das sind
-auch alles keine Expert*innen.
-Ich verstehe das gar nicht. Ich merk nur,
dass tatsächlich ich so ein bisschen
denke, Mensch, die 16-Jährigen hier,
die sollen froh sein, dass sie da nicht
mitmachen müssen.
-Na dann komm rüber.
-Nee, nee, nee, nee, andersrum. Nee, nee,
das ist komplexer. Die sollten
vielleicht eine neue Partei gründen oder vielleicht
sogar zwei neue Parteien gründen. Es ist
ja unglaublich, was da eigentlich läuft
mit den großen Volksparteien, sage
ich mal, was die sich so trauen. Das ist
wirklich... Also und dass man
den jungen Leuten...
-Was trauen sie sich?
-Naja, die bescheißen ohne Ende, die lügen
und betrügen und die müssen
eigentlich alle ins Gefängnis.
Also ich glaube,
Politikverdrossenheit hilft dir nicht weiter.
Ich weiß, ich wollte nur eins sagen:
Ich finde, die Jugendlichen sollten sich jetzt
richtig stark machen und ein eigenes
politisches System gründen,
bei dem die anderen wirklich keine
Rolle mehr spielen, weil die haben es wirklich
versemmelt. Aber so richtig
versemmelt. Und ich denke jetzt gerade in den Zeiten
der Pandemie hoffen einige, die ich so
kenne, auf eine große Transformation,
als wäre das eine Chance, Krise als Chance.
Dass es jetzt eine Transformation
gibt, dass die Welt sich neu
gestaltet. Und dazu finde ich, dass es gehört,
dass man sagt ja, z.B. 16-jährige
können wählen. Das ist ja auch immer so gewesen,
dass Frauen nicht wählen durften. Und die durften
dann irgendwann wählen. Da gab
es auch Streitigkeiten, dass die irgendwie
eigentlich kein Recht haben. Dann war mal
21, dann war 18, jetzt ist vielleicht
16 und es müssen Prozesse in Gang kommen
und man kann ja so dankbar sein,
wenn man an den alten Strukturen noch hängt,
dass tatsächlich neue Leute
sich einbringen mit so einer Vehemenz,
um am Ende die alten Strukturen zu halten.
Weil wenn es dann wirklich kein Interesse
mehr gibt bei den jungen Leuten und die sagen
"Lasst die machen, wir machen
den Arsch zu und beschäftigen
uns mit etwas ganz anderem", dann sieht
-es eigentlich noch schlimmer aus.
-Nehmen wir doch mal eins von den weniger
komödiantischen Argumenten. Sarah, du
bist trotzdem nach hinten gegangen. Aber
der Punkt, ist der vielleicht valide
für dich? Also dass wenn man junge Leute
mit 16 schon einbindet und mit entsprechenden
politischen
Bildungsmaßnahmen begleitet, dass man
dann eben vielleicht auch dem entgegenwirkt,
dass die der Demokratie
den Rücken zudrehen?
Die Realität sieht so aus: Ich sitze
ja im Wahllokal seit ein paar Jahren
bei den Kommunalwahlen, also jetzt
schon zweimal. Und da sehe ich ja, wer ist
mit 16 wahlberechtigt und wer geht
hin. Und ich sehe es auch an übergeordneten
Statistiken und das ist einfach nicht
die Masse auch im Durchschnitt verglichen
zu den Erwachsenen. Und das zeigt
für mich einfach: Die Leute bekommen
ihre Wahlbenachrichtigung und sagen
dann schon mal eher "Okay, die wandert jetzt
in den Müll, anstatt dass ich jetzt
aktiv wählen gehe". Also ich glaube nicht,
dass es das bringt, um die Menschen
mehr zu politisieren.
Ich frage mal dich, Anna, du bist ja
nun eine Repräsentantin einer grünen Partei.
Und es ist ja schon auffällig, dass Grüne,
SPD, FDP meistens auch und die SPD
für ein Wahlrecht ab 16 sind und CDU
und AfD, wenn ich das richtig sehe,
eher dagegen sind. Und wir wissen
tatsächlich auch durch Umfragen,
dass mutmaßlich die Parteien, die dafür
sind, auch davon profitieren würden.
Ist es am Ende - und den Verdacht,
den haben ja viele - dann doch
-nur ein politisches Geschacher?
-Darum geht es ja überhaupt nicht. Uns geht
es darum, dass man eben Menschen
befähigt, an politischen Entscheidungen
und an Entscheidungen der Zukunft
teilzuhaben. Und nur weil wir jetzt
unter 18-Jährigen diese Entscheidung
geben würden, sagen wir ja nicht "Ah, hier ist
übrigens noch einen Brief, du sollst
für uns stimmen!" Es geht vor allem darum,
dass aus diesem Frust, der ja auch entstanden
ist durch Fridays for future...
zweieinhalb Jahre, drei Jahre wurde auf die Straße
gegangen. Und was ist passiert?
Also das Kohleausstiegsgesetz ist
immer noch 2038. Herzlichen Glückwunsch!
-Es bringt uns gar nicht.
-Ich finde, das ist zum Beispiel sehr weit.
-Und du sagst, das reicht noch nicht.
-Ne das reicht auf gar keinen Fall.
Aber das zeigt doch auf, dass wir komplett
unterschiedliche Bewertungen haben,
auch in der Sache. Und man kann
deshalb nicht so festsetzen "Ja, die Älteren
oder die Politik tut gar nichts, nimmt
gar nichts auf" oder "Nimmt alles komplett
auf". Also ich glaube, dass da sehr viel
Wertendes auch mit reinspielt spielt,
dass es auf keinen Fall
jetzt so pauschal zu sagen ist.
-Darf ich mal sagen, dass...
-Ah, warum bist du vorgegangen? Das ist
wichtig, weil es geht in dieser Sendung
ums Zusammenkommen.
Ich verstehe, dass die Angst davor da ist,
gerade wenn man in einer Partei ist,
dass dann junge Menschen die eine Partei
wählen oder die andere. Aber eben, ich sag
ja auch nicht Wahlrecht nur für Menschen,
die die Grünen wählen. Sondern ich nehme
sozusagen in Kauf, dass Menschen auch Parteien
wählen würden, die ich vielleicht
gar nicht vertrete. Und als Gegenargument
höre ich "Nein, nein, was ist, wenn man
dann programmatisch wählt?" Das finde
ich total blöd, aber ich stimme dir zu,
dass es unterschiedliche Meinungen
gibt und ich würde lieber eine total...I
don't know Entscheidungen haben, wo ich mir
denken würde "Huch, was ist denn
da passiert?" Aber die kommt von jungen
Menschen, da könnte ich viel mehr
-mitgehen.
-Stephan hast du total überzeugt, der ist
-gleich zwei Schritte nach vorne gegangen.
-Mit einem Argument stimme ich dir völlig
zu: Die Frage, was jemand wählt,
darf nicht entscheidend sein bei der Frage,
wie das Wahlrecht
entschieden wird, stimme ich dir völlig zu.
Okay, wir sind ja...Ich muss aber
mal sagen, wenn wir kurz zusammenfassen:
Es war viel Bewegung, vor allem
Stephan ist viel auf seiner Geraden hin und her
gedüst. Aber tatsächlich habt ihr euch
alle ein bisschen bewegt und es sind
relativ viele auch relativ weit
gekommen. Und was ich ehrlicherweise am Anfang nicht
gedacht habe, dass du auch relativ
weit auf ihn zugehst, hab ich am Anfang nicht
so vermutet, aber so ist das in dieser Sendung.
Also da stehen wir. Jetzt gucke
ich mal, ob ich euch noch
weiter nach vorne bringen kann. Wir gehen
in die Kompromissrunde. Und bei der Kompromissrunde
ist es folgendermaßen:
Ich schlage einen Kompromiss vor, wo ich jetzt
glaube, nach dieser Diskussion,
haben wir so einen Minimalkonsens
und danach könnt ihr selber Kompromisse
vorschlagen und versuchen, die andere
Seite nochmal zu euch zu ziehen. Also
mein Kompromiss und das ist jetzt
wirklich ein Minimalkonsens: Also jetzt mal ganz
unabhängig davon, ob das Wahlrecht
ab 16 kommt oder nicht. Wir wollen -
ich formuliere jetzt für euch als Gruppe
- Wir wollen, dass Schüler*innen
in der politischen Bildung gestärkt
werden zum Wohle der Demokratie logischerweise
und auch um potentielle
Wahlentscheidungen treffen zu können. Deswegen soll
es in der Schule ein Pflichtfach
Politik geben, gerne schon ab der Grundschule.
Stimmt ihr zu? Dann kommt ihr bitte
nach vorne, wenn ihr sagt Nein, das ist mir
zu blöd, bleibt stehen oder geht
nach hinten. Du findest das nicht.
Ja, ich habe ein Problem damit,
wenn man immer direkt in den Bildungsplan
eingreift. Jede Partei bei jeder
Landtagswahl will irgendwie
den Bildungsplan ändern. Die FDP
kommt mit Wirtschaft an, die CDU oder andere
Parteien sagen dann irgendwie Ja, wie ist
es mit islamischen Religionsunterricht?
Also ich würde jetzt von der Pflicht
im Bildungsplan absehen.
-Interessant.
-Das ist mir zu pauschal.
Gut. Du findest Politikunterricht
langweilig, deswegen bleibst du stehen?
Ne, ich finde es eigentlich eine gute
Idee, aber nicht ab der Grundschule.
-Das braucht man nicht.
-Deshalb bist du auch nur einen halben
-Schritt vorgegangen.
-Aber sonst stimme ich zu. Ich finde, es
sollte verpflichtend in allen
Schulen ab einem gewissen Alter, sechste,
-siebte Klasse Politikunterricht geben.
-Was ja momentan de facto nicht so ist. So,
jetzt merkt ihr euch bitte ganz
genau, wo ihr steht und dann kommt ihr in eurer
Gruppe zusammen und überlegt mal, ob ihr einen
Kompromiss findet, wo ihr sagt,
da stimmen die anderen bestimmt zu,
die kommen auf uns zu. Okay? Alles klar
-und los.
-Junge Menschen betreffen darf das
-Wahlrecht...
-Eine Minute Zeit für die beiden Gruppen,
um einen Kompromiss zu finden. Was wäre
denn euer Kompromiss? Wie würdet ihr Gelb
und Grün näher zusammenbringen?
Schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare. Wer weiß,
vielleicht wird es irgendwann
Wirklichkeit.
Das Wahlrecht alleine
wird nicht alles ändern.
So, sind wir so weit? Ihr wisst
noch ungefähr, wo ihr gestanden habt?
Tracy stand auf der Linie, genau.
Relativ weit vorne. So, Team gelb: Habt ihr einen
-Kompromissvorschlag?
-Nicht wir drei zusammen.
-Nicht ihr drei zusammen?
-Nein.
Okay. Was ist ein Vorschlag?
Gibt's einen oder gibt's zwei?
Ich finde z.B. die Kommunalwahlen
ab 16 in Ordnung mit der Begründung,
dass nur die Exekutive gewählt wird.
Aber so ist momentan auch der Ist-Zustand,
deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob es ein richtiger
Kompromiss ist.
Okay, aber bei Landtagswahlen
bist du schon wieder raus.
Genau, weil die eben auch Gesetze
machen. Der Föderalismus ist ja schon stark.
-Ja, okay. Und du?
-Also ich finde, man kann bei
Landtagswahlen ab 16 wählen. Und ich finde,
wenn man wirklich alle versucht
mit einzubeziehen, mit verpflichtendem
Politikunterricht, mit anderen kreativen
Ideen, wie man wirklich Jugendliche
von Politik begeistern kann und zum Wählen
anregen, kann man in acht Jahren
z.B. darüber ernsthaft sprechen kann, ob man
-das Wahlrecht senkt.
-Können wir zur nächsten Bundestagswahl
-sagen?
-Wenn wir jetzt hier starten.
-Ja, okay.
-Also in 5 Jahren? Oh, du hast deine
-Team-Mitglieder vergrault.
-Aber er ist jung halt, er hat recht.
Ja gut, ein Evaluierungsprozess
war das, hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Mir wäre übernächste Wahl lieber,
aber wenn man jetzt startet und das wirklich
offensiv angeht, so viele wie möglich
einzubinden, dann sage ich ja.
-Friedrich bleibt trotzdem stehen.
-Äh ne, ich finde es gut.
Mal sehen, jetzt seid ihr ein bisschen
nach hinten gerutscht durch den eigenen
Vorschlag. Was habt
ihr für einen Vorschlag?
Dass wir einen Jugendrat auf Bundesebene
einführen, der zumindest beratend zuerst
hinzugezogen wird, damit man sich
einen Eindruck machen kann, was die Jugend denn
will und nicht immer schauen
muss: Was gibt's da für Protestbewegungen?
Sondern wirklich auch das wertschätzt
glaub ich auch, das Engagement von jungen
Menschen. Und wirklich diese Vernetzung
hat auf Bundesebene.
Also der Vorschlag steht im Raum:
Wir gründen einen Jugendrat,
der per Losverfahren z.B. bestimmt
wird, der bei wichtigen politischen Fragen
-angehört werden muss. Sofort dafür.
-Und zur nächsten Bundestagswahl...
Da bin ich dann wieder da hinten.
Kompromisse sind immer nur Kompromisse,
-wenn man nicht noch so Nachsätze ranhängt.
-Kein Nachsatz. So ähnlich könnte 13 Fragen
funktionieren. Herzlichen Dank. Ihr seid
jetzt hier vorne fast alle angekommen.
Ich freue mich. Vielen Dank fürs
Mitmachen. Und wenn ihr noch einen
Vorschlag habt, dann bitte schreibt
es einfach rein. Hätte euch das überzeugt?
Würde mich jetzt auch mal
interessieren. Ein Jugendrat per Losverfahren. Es kann
also sein, dass du bald mit Angela
Merkel im Kanzleramt sitzt und sagst "So nicht,
Frau Merkel!" Vielen,
vielen Dank! Das waren "13 Fragen".
Ich finde, es sollte zwei neue
Parteien geben, damit die jungen Leute auch wieder
etwas Neues zu tun kriegen. Eine sollte
heißen "Rosa" und so ähnlich
sein wie die Grünen, die sich sehr für Pflanzen
und Tiere eingesetzt haben und so
gut, dass jetzt alle Parteien
darüber reden. Und es sollte sich "Rosa"
für Menschen einsetzen. Also
Wellness, Gesundheit, auch psychische Gesundheit
und alles, damit der Mensch richtig
gut gedeiht und wächst und alt wird und schön
ist. Das macht die rosa Partei. Und dann
gibt es eine Partei, die heißen "Die
ersten Vertikalisten". Das ist
eine Partei, die hat rausgekriegt,
dass es eigentlich nie um rechts, links
oder Mitte geht, sondern immer nur um oben
und unten. Und dass es da auch Missverständnisse
gibt. Und diese Partei
kümmert sich halt darum. Und da hätten
die jungen Leute was, wo sie sagen "Wow, ja,
-das ist neu, das nehme ich".
-Also die Parteien müssen ja auch gewählt
werden. Ich glaube, daran
scheitert es dann eventuell.
Nee, nee, die jungen Leute, das müsste
schon so sein, dass junge Leute das mögen.
Also ich glaube, dass uns allen klar
ist, dass wir vor allem bei der Bildung
ansetzen müssen. Beim Interesse, dass wir für alle
Jugendlichen genug Interesse
-schaffen, um wählen zu gehen.
-Ja ich glaube, dass es unheimlich wichtig
ist, dass die Diskussion nicht nur hier
bleibt, sondern wie gesagt auch in Schulen
getragen wird. Und vor allem, dass wir ja
hier heute auch schon Politik zusammen
gemacht haben, gestritten haben,
versucht haben, am Ende auch teilweise aufeinander
-zuzugehen.
-Also ich glaube, wir sind uns in einem
-ähnlich: Wir spitzen beide gerne zu.
-Ja.
Weil nur wenn man seine Meinung
auch ziemlich klar sagt, kann man ja
auch nur einen Kompromiss finden. Und wir haben
uns gekabbelt, wir haben grade
drüber geredet. Also ich fühle mich
jetzt nicht reduziert auf alter weißer Mann.
Also alt fühle ich mich sowieso
nicht. Weiß bin ich nun mal, Mann kann
ich auch nicht bestreiten,
aber das ist nicht mein Leben.
-Total.
-Und mit solchen Klischees kann ich nichts
-anfangen.
-Ich glaube, dieser Begriff kommt oft
verletzend rüber und ich glaube, dass es nur wichtig
ist für mich gerade z.B.,
mit meiner Lebensgeschichte, da gar
nicht so viel rein zu interpretieren,
sondern anzuerkennen, dass es verschiedene
Perspektiven gibt und trotzdem kann man
im Austausch sein und ich glaube, es muss
mehr Austausch passieren, weil gerade
solche Debatten finden glaube ich selten
statt und auch, dass man sich wo treffen
kann und nicht, dass man im Streit
auseinander geht, sondern z.B. dass du
hörst, dass es mir ein ganz dolles
Anliegen ist, was ist eine Möglichkeit,
was ist eine neue Form, was ist ein Update
für die Demokratie, mit der du leben
-könntest?
-Also ich fände es toll, wenn wir die
Diskussion fortsetzen können. Jetzt
bin ich aus Bonn und du bist in Berlin
und Corona usw. Aber wir können doch
direkt vereinbaren: In den nächsten Tagen
-machen wir eine Zoom-Diskussion.
-Ja.
Und dann gehen wir mal auf die Inhalte,
nicht nur auf Formalia Wahlrecht,
sondern dann reden wir mal drüber:
Wie ist das mit Kohleausstieg? Wie ist
-es mit der Umweltpolitik und so weiter.
-Ja.
Und insofern: Ihr könnt euch
dann wieder zuschalten, wenn ihr wollt.
-Ja.
-Was ja klar ist, wenn das Schiff, das wir
Demokratie nennen, nicht
untergehen soll, dann müssen sich mehr Menschen
und auch mehr junge Menschen
politisch interessieren und engagieren. Und da bin
ich ganz froh, da herrscht in dieser Runde
eine große Einigkeit. Wenn euch
unser Format "13 Fragen" gefällt,
dann könnt ihr hier unseren Kanal abonnieren,
hier oben gibt's eine weitere Folge
"13 Fragen" und hier findet ihr ein weiteres
Video zum Thema.